law what is it good for absolutely
excellent Ace Attorney games and now
it's jumping over a hundred years back
in time to star Phoenix Wright's
barrister ancestor I'm said bored and
you're watching a GS news update
series creator shoot Akuma is at work on
a brand new Ace Attorney game for 3s
that takes the series more than a
century into the past
according to details from the latest
from it soo as translated by silicon era
the great Ace Attorney is set during
Japan's Meiji period which took place
from 1868 to 1912 players will assume
the role of Maria no skåne era hodo an
ancestor of Phoenix Wright whose last
name is Nara hodo in Japanese the game
is set to come to 3ds and will be
directed by Takumi also involved with
the development is producer Shintaro
Kojima whose previous work includes the
Monster Hunter series details beyond the
setting and names which keep in mind
haven't been announced in English yet
were not shared the most recent game in
the Ace Attorney series to be released
in North America was Phoenix Wright Ace
Attorney dual destinies for 3ds last
October meanwhile the spin-off Professor
Layton vs Phoenix Wright is scheduled
for release on 3ds sometime this year do
you have any objections to a bit of old
timey law or is the jury still out do
you have any better legal puns do you
let me know in the comments or on
Twitter and if you'd like to
cross-examine more stories just head
over to GameSpot calm slash news
I'm